in this first problem over here we're
asked to find out the length of this
segment segment ce and we have these two
parallel lines a b is parallel to d e
and then we have these two essentially
transversals that form these two
triangles so let's see what we can do
here so the first thing that might jump
out at you is that this angle and this
angle are vertical angles so they are
going to be congruent the other thing
that might jump out at you is that angle
c d e
saying angle c d e is an alternate
interior angle with cba so we have this
transversal right over here and these
are alternate interior angles and they
are going to be congruent or you could
say that if you continue this
transversal you would have a
corresponding angle with cde right up
here and that this one's just vertical
either way this angle and this angle are
going to be congruent so we've
established that we have two triangles
and they have two
two of the corresponding angles are the
same and that by itself is enough to
establish similarity you can actually we
actually could show that this angle and
this angle are also congruent by
alternate interior angles but we don't
have to so we already know that they are
similar actually we could just say it
just
by alternate interior angles these are
also going to be congruent but we've
already we already know enough to say
that they are similar even before doing
that so we already know that triangle
i'll try to write it i'll color code it
so that we have the same corresponding
vertices and that's really important to
know what angles and what sides
correspond to what side so that you
don't mess up your i guess your ratios
or so that you do know what's
corresponding to what so we know
triangle
a
b
triangle a
b c
a b c
is similar
is similar to triangle so a this vertex
a corresponds to vertex e over here
is similar to vertex e and then vertex b
right over here corresponds to vertex d
e
d
d c
e d c now what does that do for us well
that tells us that the ratio of
corresponding sides are going to have
the same they're going to be the same
they're going to be some constant value
so we have corresponding side so the
ratio for example the corresponding side
for bc
the corresponding side for bc is going
to be dc we can see it just the way that
we've written down the similarity if
this is true then bc is the
corresponding side to dc so we know that
bc
the length of bc over
dc right over here over dc
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to the length of
well we want to figure out what ce is
that's what we care about and i'm using
bc and dc because we know those values
so bc over dc is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to what's the
corresponding side to c e
c e the corresponding side over here c a
is going to be equal to c a
over
c
e
a over c e corresponding sides this is
the last and the first last and the
first c a over c e and we know what bc
is
bc right over here
is five we know what dc is it is three
we know what ca or ac is right over here
ca is four
and now we can just solve for c e so we
can well there's multiple ways that you
could think about this
you could cross multiply
and you get which is really just
multiplying both sides by both
denominators so you get 5
times the length of ce five times the
length of ce is equal to three times
four
which is just going to be equal to
twelve and then we get c e
c e is equal to twelve over five
is equal to twelve over five which is
the same thing as two and two fifths
two and two fifths or two point four so
this is going to be two
and two-fifths and we're done we were
able to use similarity to figure out
this side just knowing that the ratio
between the corresponding sides are
going to be the same
now let's do this problem right over
here let's do this one let me draw a
little line here to show that this is a
different problem now
this is a different problem so in this
problem we need to figure out what d e
is and we all once again have these two
we have these two parallel lines like
this and so we know corresponding angles
are congruent so we know that angle is
going to be congruent to that angle
because you could view this as a
transversal we also know that this angle
right over here
we also know that this angle right over
here is going to be congruent to that
angle right over there
once again corresponding angles for
transversal and also in both triangles
so i'm looking at triangle cbd and
triangle c a e they both share this
angle up here
they both share this angle up here so
we've actually shown once again we could
have stopped at two angles but we've
actually shown that all three angles of
these two triangles all three of the
corresponding angles are congruent to
each other so we now know we now know
once again this is important thing to do
is to make sure that you get is that you
write it in the right order when you
write your similarity we now know that
triangle c
c
b
b d
c b d
is similar
is similar not congruent it is similar
to triangle
c
a
e
c a
c a e which means that the ratio of
corresponding sides are going to be
constant so we know for example that the
ratio between cb is going to be the same
the ratio for of cb to ca
so let's write this down we know that
the ratio of
cb over ca
is going to be equal to the ratio of c d
c d
over c e
and we know what c b is cb over here is
5. we know what c a is and we have to be
careful here it's not three c a this
entire side is going to be five plus
three so this is going to be eight
and we know what c d is c d is going to
be four and so once again
we can cross multiply we have five c e
five times c e
is equal to
eight times eight times four eight times
four is 32 32 and so ce is equal to
c e
is equal to 32
32 over 5. or this is another way to
think about that's six and two-fifths
6 and two-fifths now we're not done
because they didn't ask for what c e is
they're asking for just this part right
over here they're asking for d e so we
know that this entire length c e right
over here this is six
and two fifths and so d e right over
here what we actually have to figure out
it's going to be this entire length six
and two-fifths minus four minus cd right
over here so it's going to be two
two and two-fifths six and two-fifths
minus four and two-fifths is two and
two-fifths so we're done d e is two and
two-fifths